preferred to be young college kids why
would you target them
investigators search for a suspect and
the murder weapon and the vicious
killings of four college students in
Moscow Idaho
the killer Still Remains at large and
that has left a real sense of fear
[Music]
it's scary being here and it doesn't
feel like home anymore it doesn't feel
as safe
the person might have targeted the home
because there was all girls that lived
at the home
are you going to catch this killer we
are doing everything we can
[Music]
it could be any student house in the
remote town of Moscow Idaho
the young women living there would throw
parties or gather round a fire pit on
the patio
their lives documented on social media
[Music]
but four weeks ago this student idle was
shattered
three of the housemates Kaylee gonsalves
Maddie Mogan and Zana kernodle and
sana's boyfriend Ethan Chapin were
brutally murdered
as they slept in bed in the early hours
of a Sunday morning they were stabbed to
death with a large knife
leaving their rooms blood splattered
there are no Witnesses nobody even
reporting hearing screams there was no
sign of forced entry at this house and
no evidence that any of the victims had
been sexually assaulted more than four
weeks on there's no murder weapon and no
suspect it's a crime that's not only
dumbfounded police it's mystified
America
its Center is a Small Town police force
which hadn't had a murder for more than
seven years
you can feel the weight of what's
happened as you walk through town and
it's hard to say if or when it will ever
be the same are you going to catch this
killer or kill us we are doing
everything we can
and part of that is to be sure we're
going through all the evidence it's vast
there there's pictures emails phone
calls coming in we have to look through
everything to make sure we have
everything we need to to make an arrest
and also take this to court and be
successful in finding Justice you want a
conviction as well as an arrest then yes
we we can't afford a mistake we can't
afford to put out information that might
compromise anything we're doing with the
investigation
[Music]
even usually joyful occasions in Moscow
are now colored by loss
victim Kaylee gonsalves was supposed to
be graduating this weekend
[Music]
this is a university and a town
terrorized by a killer on the loose are
you feeling safe neither oh no
um I have like pepper spray and I have
different kind of self
self-help things but it's scary it's
scary being here and it doesn't feel
like home anymore it doesn't feel as
safe I knew two of the girls from middle
school then I tutored Ethan for a little
bit I knew them thinking about them
always
um I have like the bracelet for him
right now we're at to graduation just
thinking about them but it's it's been
tough being here Ethan like lit up a
room when he went into it he was just
always smiling so happy so funny yeah
I'm just so lucky I got to know them
Trevor Adkins daughter Katie lives down
the street from where the murders
happened I just put myself in their
shoes and it just makes me sick to my
stomach and those sweet girls
for young women particularly walking
home in the dark here I can't imagine
how that feels at the moment yeah it's
pretty terrifying and when we checked
into the Airbnb I was scared to death
and my made my husband like chicken or
the bed and I'm like a 43 year old woman
and I couldn't believe it and I got in
there and the windows weren't locked and
it just paralyzed me and so I shut all
the windows and I closed the curtains I
checked under everywhere
one of the many unknowns pervading this
case is why the three-story house or its
occupants were targeted and why some
were left alive
on the first floor Zana and her
boyfriend Ethan who were sharing a bed
were killed
on the second floor Kaylee and lifelong
best friend Maddie also sharing a bed
were murdered two other female
housemates in ground floor bedrooms say
they slept through the attacks when they
woke they summoned other friends to the
house believing one housemate to be
unconscious police have ruled them out
as suspects why would you target these
kids why would you do that Troy lamba is
a crime writer his stepson lives in the
apartments overlooking the murder house
did he say he heard anything on the yeah
he was working that night so he didn't
he wasn't home until late and then of
course him and his roommate do gaming
and stuff like that so they didn't hear
anything either I mean with the density
of students in this area that is kind of
surprising that nobody heard anything
have you got any theories well my my
only theory is that it was someone
organized who knew what they were doing
and knew them
um the biggest question is motive first
of all like who was it how close within
their Circle were they and then what was
their motive for doing it I mean to kids
for it to be College young college kids
who have no no what I would consider no
enemies really like why would you target
them
investigators say they're busy piecing
together not just what happened inside
the house but the hours leading up to
the murders
muddy and Kaylee had spent the night at
this bar just off the main street in
Moscow leaving at 1am to walk to a
nearby food truck I think I would like
Kaylee can be heard ordering there then
appears to be a dispute with a man in a
hoodie at one point Maddie gestures
towards him police say they've
discounted this man as a suspect
Kaylee gonsalves as family frustrated
with the lack of information from the
police have recruited a lawyer to push
for answers I don't think that the
family
believes that there was an individual
Target on their daughter
it just doesn't make sense with the
um the facts that have been presented
and other information that we've
gathered
um you know the person might have
targeted the home
because there were all girls that lived
at the home and it was a house that
there a lot of people came and went in a
very social scene that the girls were
involved with and and they were
sororities in their sorority and and and
things like that mystery also surrounds
the whereabouts of the other two victims
the night before the murders
this is the sigma Chief fraternity house
with the Greek lettering
Zana and Ethan were here between 8 and 9
p.m the evening before the murders
it's less than a five minute walk from
the house where they were killed yet
they didn't return here until 1 45 a.m
police are now trying to account for
those missing five hours
there are so many unknowns in a
community desperate for answers four
families now approaching Christmas not
knowing why their lives were suddenly
and violently ripped apart or by whom
Martha calnet Sky News Idaho